Ishak VT: Gutenmorgen Kajana.
Kajana: It didn't longer.
Ishak VT: a good Morganafna.
Ishak VT: Ana.
Ishak VT: eine ganze woche was du nicht.
Ishak VT: Was it supposed to eat?
Kajana: Ishbah.
Kajana: Can I speak in English?
Kajana: rightages were in, FIBA?
Ishak VT: Head to FIBA.
Kajana: Yeah.
Kajana: Ishaate fever, Monday and Tuesday.
Kajana: I had to attend my… my uncle's.
Kajana: Alright.
Ishak VT: Oh, okay, okay, shadow, okay.
Kajana: Yeah, that's why I couldn't attend the class.
Ishak VT: Okay, the Swagen, konte ist den untakish nicht Besochen, yeah? Nishk common order was… okay. The Swagen, that's why Konte-ish nicht. So, we haben feel guilant, we kionnen sie dasweiter. Sie haben feel vermist, verbal.
Kajana: Yeah.
Ishak VT: A lot. So, we can envy this white layer, and how… would you get the recording, or what? I don't know.
Kajana: Yeah, yeah.
Ishak VT: A bit of a suckenzie, because weil sie eine guten grund darfuh haben, a reason you have daswegen konnen sie einfach das bekomen, ja?
Ishak VT: zu erst kian wir das discutierensteren.
Ishak VT: Okay, then… yeah.
Ishak VT: Tejabidasun.
Ishak VT: sagin.
Ishak VT: Liba Marina, Mariana?
Ishak VT: vielen dank fur deine ein Ladung, ich fre mich seh auf die Reise. Wir ken viel ausfriu gemachen.
Ishak VT: ist the winter, while daswetag ange name… East.
Ishak VT: You missed the verb here.
Ishak VT: Of now?
Ishak VT: While the Sveta and Genem East.
Fathima Afna: We stood, yeah.
Ishak VT: is stored or something, yeah? Some verb should be there, because the weather will be
Ishak VT: convenient, and gonna be very pleasant, yeah? Im zone ist des auf zu heis.
Ishak VT: Du soltest Leichste Kleidung mitbringen mitbringen. Sohn agrieme und eine Son Brilles sind, ja, sehr.
Ishak VT: und die culture inform… Okay, one second.
Ishak VT: Du kanst dich gut auf die Reise for Brighton, when do, dich uber, very good, das wetter und die cultur informheist.
Ishak VT: Ich froin mich auf deinen.
Ishak VT: No error. No error. But you can make it better. Some more, adding sentence. You change this way, this, auf deinen besuch frauch mich sehr.
Ishak VT: I'm very happy. You can just start with aufdainen, so… no problem, just… it's just that. And, yeah.
Ishak VT: And… so… okay, they're good.
Ishak VT: Very good, Gemaktia.
Ishak VT: So, Mahanzi waiter, you know, underre fragen, modal test in ja.
Ishak VT: abaya.
Ishak VT: Okay.
Ishak VT: begin and via… Zoo.
Ishak VT: Yeah, Hoyte, beginan via mid capital.
Ishak VT: Fear… Capital FEER HABA.
Ishak VT: Das haben wir schon in Art Zweigeland, comparative.
Ishak VT: Gut, Besser Ambestin. Yeah, we haben KleinKleiner, ein kleinsten.
Ishak VT: You know, right? Combative.
Ishak VT: So, when sie sachen… Fagglycin. Ferg glycis was… Her glycin.
Ishak VT: Okay, this niya for glycin bedoit to compare.
Ishak VT: Two things. Yeah? Mein Brute ist Elte als ich.
Ishak VT: He's older than me.
Ishak VT: So, my Natasha is grosser Eich als, die Natasha.
Ishak VT: Okay, Dunk.
Ishak VT: Zoo… nigminuten.
Ishak VT: So, we have been, afna hat gut rib nichtwurzagan, yeah, we have been shown just… Gilesen, this…
Ishak VT: as Steineer Guter, brief.
Ishak VT: Alright, sorry.
Ishak VT: So, in Moment Bitter… the cyst… This is Sanagia…
Ishak VT: Just to read through this, it's a very good one. There's no error, not a single error, Ziyat Kemakt, yeah?
Ishak VT: Bitter, bitter, bitter, bitter.
Ishak VT: So, here, only one mistake. That is a mis,
Ishak VT: But she, by carelessness, it happened, while the Sveta and Giname etched.
Ishak VT: All others are perfect sentences. But…
Ishak VT: add more, zoneden auch, Nishnu au zoneden auch Entweder, ziken Entweder, eine Zone Bringle. Mitbrinken. Sovol Zonen Krime also auch eine Zonen Brindles.
Ishak VT: ist auch wichtig? You can just say, right? You can just use here.
Ishak VT: Wenzo.
Ishak VT: Here, also.au.
Ishak VT: Uber di kultura informies. You can just use others also.
Ishak VT: Okay.
Ishak VT: But you have used this when Nebenzad's Very good.
Ishak VT: Yeah, bitter, bitter, bitter, bitter.
Ishak VT: be komen.
Ishak VT: O si se spoiled.
Arafath: Just, just now uploaded to the…
Ishak VT: Uploaded is a good ja, we are kionnen, das, they're good.
Ishak VT: And moment… this is… Submission Gistan, yeah?
Ishak VT: Abdulazeus, okay.
Ishak VT: Ich nicht edgesch.
Arafath: I am fine alone.
Ishak VT: This one, right?
Arafath: Yeah, a small one.
Ishak VT: That's one.
Arafath: Actually, actually, actually, when I, when I, when I speak about, I mean, I mean, myself, like that, I go out there, I, I, I, I, I'm playing, he's playing, like, I can, I can write. So, when it, when I turn into that, I mean, a speech, like, it's like a speech, no.
Ishak VT: Kind of, yeah.
Arafath: article.
Ishak VT: topic.
Arafath: topic. It's very… it's very hard to structure the topic. I mean, the structure.
Ishak VT: To send it, yeah.
Arafath: when I… when we speak about the, I'm going to… I'm going to hiking, and…
Ishak VT: Small sentence… small sentences is… is Ganza Infach, yeah?
Ishak VT: Sentence is uber, uber sich, ja, wirkjonnen. Das ist ganz einfach. Ich ste, umsehen auf ja.
Arafath: Yeah.
Ishak VT: So, these are imaltag vs. So, this is… we have… we listen, we have been, we are… we have got used to that. That's why it's easy. It was not easy in the beginning.
Ishak VT: When, when, when in… when sie in Azwei oder a eins waren, wars nicht einfach.
Ishak VT: icht.
Ishak VT: So, so many sentences, yeah? So, when we are Nebenzatz learnnen, yeah? Wenzatz undiesatz, obvoelsatz, wir machen, wir haben feelispiele geschrieben, ja, viel beespiele. Das wagen istes sein vah.
Ishak VT: This kind of topic, we are… we haven't… I, in fact, just begonin.
Ishak VT: This kind of topic. So, it will become Aussie. Ich werder, es werda, Easier einfacher weden werden.
Ishak VT: it is werd einfacher werden. It will also become easy when you do it more. That's it.
Arafath: And of course, vocabulary also heating.
Ishak VT: No, yeah.
Ishak VT: Vocabulary is something that you…
Ishak VT: have to work on that, you have to work on that, you have to learn. Lesen sie einen Text jeden tag. Einen guten Text.
Ishak VT: mit capital dry an fangen, Neue Jorte bekommen.
Ishak VT: So, just write it down in sentences. Vertile is, was, advantageous. So, note that. Just Benutzensi.
Ishak VT: Then, Erin is to, Erin Ehren zh, daran, Emma. You remember that. That's… that's the only way, otherwise a vocabulary learning is, nicht me joglich hin einem tag.
Ishak VT: Mein vocabulary istes Schlescht.
Ishak VT: Ich ken keine Jorte Ehren. Das ist sind close problem. Sie konnen, diese vocabulary in Ainam Targoreen eine Woche nicht machen.
Ishak VT: This is unmoglash. Impossible. So start today.
Ishak VT: leisen und Neue worte learnen gehen zusammen zamen.
Ishak VT: So, neue wert wirte learnen, wenn sie leisen.
Ishak VT: Lesen Sie in einem Satz, wenn sie, you see.
Ishak VT: Mmm…
Ishak VT: So, in the uni mensa, zolte es nuerwegettari segarishti gemeben.
Ishak VT: It should be. Es gibbt was bidoit, es gibt, es gibt einen ein buch auf dem Tisch. Es gibt.
Ishak VT: Eskept… what is a respiratory escaped. Eskept einen, ein buch auf dem Tisch.
Arafath: There's… there's a…
Ishak VT: There is, right?
Ishak VT: There is. Es gibtis, there is and there are. Es gibti fuhen fur mit gleeder in meine familia. There are…
Ishak VT: 5 members. So, the reason there are is… what?
Ishak VT: The same word, escaped, escaped. What is meaning escaped? There is. Eskipt eine katze in meinem Haus.
Ishak VT: There's a cat.
Ishak VT: Escape to try ketz.
Ishak VT: Ketzen in Meinemhausen. There are to get. So, how do you use Zolte? As you see, the same word.
Ishak VT: In the unimenza, zolte es noegitari se gerichte gemben.
Ishak VT: There should be, you see? S gift is what?
Ishak VT: There is. There should be. That's it.
Ishak VT: Come back to me, come back to me, don't, don't miss… One second… yeah.
Ishak VT: Here.
Ishak VT: S. Keep.
Ishak VT: East. There are, there is.
Ishak VT: There is… So, the eine Beichspiel S. Gibt, Noah… Vega… we get… Tarisher… Girchta?
Ishak VT: in the… What is it?
Ishak VT: In the university, in the Uni. Gerichta. Girichta?
Ishak VT: in the UNI, Skipt nuovigitte in the…
Ishak VT: Unique University. You see, there is…
Ishak VT: I would argue. There is no Vegitara Shigerichte in the UNI, sorry, in the F. Okay? In the. So, now.
Ishak VT: You're learning skipped, okay, verb. So, how does it…
Ishak VT: There is… there will be only vegetarian food, dishes in the uni, how do you say?
Ishak VT: So, will, where then future is where then plus… Where, then?
Ishak VT: Blues?
Ishak VT: Infinitive.
Ishak VT: So, S weird, Noah, there will be. There is and there will be. S weird Noah… So, as weird…
Ishak VT: Geben. So, becomes Geben because infinitive. S weird geben bedoit it.
Ishak VT: there will be.
Ishak VT: You see? So, example.
Ishak VT: S, weird, no, we get… Vegatarishe… Gerichte.
Ishak VT: Te, Indar.
Ishak VT: Uni Gibben.
Ishak VT: Because escape car geben goes to the end because of weddin, yeah?
Ishak VT: VADEN, SO, what is the meaning? There will be. Meaning?
Ishak VT: There is becomes, there will be, because the same way, because of where then, gift becomes Gaben.
Ishak VT: This is… there is. That's how you learn. No, no, the other sentence. S… Zolta… Ezolte Gaben.
Ishak VT: What should the meaning?
Ishak VT: There… Should be.
Ishak VT: You see? So right here, what is the mistake? Should be. There should be.
Ishak VT: So?
Ishak VT: XAML, instead of where dan you put Azolta… newer… dish so ke food.
Ishak VT: Gehricht.
Ishak VT: in the… Oni… Gibbon.
Ishak VT: Meaning?
Ishak VT: What was bedroitted this? There should be.
Ishak VT: There should… As salty, there should be… it's all together.
Ishak VT: is Salta…
Ishak VT: Given.
Ishak VT: This all together.
Ishak VT: The meaning, there should be, is a salty gaben, a suede given. You see, this is the meaning.
Ishak VT: So, this is how you learn. You be sure about the usage. There should be only… Vegetarian.
Ishak VT: Vegg shit… Tyrion… Dishes.
Ishak VT: In the university.
Ishak VT: University.
Ishak VT: Here, there… will be.
Ishak VT: So, because where then is future, right? Where done first infinitive, this is… where,
Ishak VT: Modal ver plus infinitive. There will be only… The same thing.
Ishak VT: Vegetarian.
Ishak VT: dishes?
Ishak VT: in the uni. That's it!
Ishak VT: So, Esau Tegeben. So, this old, when you learn SGIPT, you should be knowing all this.
Ishak VT: So, you understood what is Vegetarisha food? Vegetarian food? Vegitaresa gerishta. Dishes gerichte. Sie haben alleged. Diese dry water haben zie mit dry Zetson.
Ishak VT: with dry Z single-ent.
Ishak VT: This how you learn.
Ishak VT: Sanchia Bistuda, okay. Okay. So, und… Mmm… yeah. This is Tells.
Ishak VT: und sie haben das G. Schrieben.
Ishak VT: Yeah, they're good. Icht demen nicht.
Ishak VT: nicholtzu.
Ishak VT: Nicht should come here. No problem, ist tim mein nicht no, ischt imme errich nicht voll kamen zu.
Ishak VT: Okay?
Ishak VT: I don't agree.
Ishak VT: So, weil nicht alla, jugentlichen, very good, jugentlichen und hoflich sind.
Ishak VT: Okay, very good. Because of Allah is, plural, sind, yeah? Very good.
Ishak VT: Libra.
Ishak VT: Meet Yeren… Mobile telephone and… Okay.
Ishak VT: So, for an enlan, so… So…
Ishak VT: Lieb, what is the verb here?
Ishak VT: What is it? What is it? What is the verb? Arafat, Bitsa. I'm just, I'm not, word by word, taking note that, okay, we are learning perfect.
Ishak VT: brauchen sie schweiss nicht, be eins oder bezwei, am enter dieses Unter Reicht mussen sie.
Ishak VT: Still, we are not sure about sentence that, and here, here, a lot to fail, but here it's perfect. We are becoming perfect, I know. What is a verb here? Es gibt keinen verb.
Ishak VT: There is no sentence over in a verb.
Ishak VT: There should be a verb. Lieber is not a verb. It's a Genka comparative, right?
Ishak VT: Ichtinke gern coffee.
Ishak VT: Ich tinke Lieber coffee.
Ishak VT: What's medoit it?
Ishak VT: I like to drink.
Ishak VT: What is the difference between ishtink… Ich trinkoffer? I like to.
Ishak VT: Any noun along with a noun, if you want to do an action, if you like to do an action, banger.
Ishak VT: Okay? When you add that, along with that verb, you put again, that's it.
Ishak VT: But if you… I like music, how do you say?
Ishak VT: Musik, Perutista. Music Nikke. How do you say? I like music.
Ishak VT: Bitter, bitter.
Ishak VT: You know it! Very simple verb.
Ishak VT: Ali, alla.
Ishak VT: Ich?
Ishak VT: I like music.
Arafath: Islib.
Ishak VT: I love music, that's correct. Ich Lieber music, but I like music, I want. Ja, ich lieber music bedeuten, I like.
Ishak VT: You know the verb mjorgen?
Ishak VT: ich.
Fathima Afna: She's smart.
Ishak VT: Ichmark muss.
Ishak VT: Music.
Ishak VT: Okay? Ishmaq Mosaic, that is correct. In moment, I'm taking this here.
Ishak VT: So, das, ich das einfach. Okay.
Ishak VT: Here.
Ishak VT: You see?
Ishak VT: Ishtrigue Gon Coffee.
Ishak VT: this is. But, when you say…
Ishak VT: I like to listen to music, how do you say?
Ishak VT: Ashura music is the verb, a sentence, that's. So, how do you like, say, I like to listen to music, a verb.
Ishak VT: That action, hearing, listening, is the action. So, I like to hear music. Listen to music. Ms. Aktman does.
Ishak VT: Ich?
Ishak VT: Kia ora?
Ishak VT: Ich jore gun music. That is a gun!
Ishak VT: His Horigen Musique.
Ishak VT: This is action, herein.
Ishak VT: Listening.
Ishak VT: No. I like… I like tea, how do you say? Ich?
Ishak VT: Issue math.
Arafath: book.
Ishak VT: Ichmarkte.
Ishak VT: So, if there's a noun, You like something or someone, Ishmaq Maria. I like her.
Ishak VT: Ich lag… Ish mug pita.
Ishak VT: Yes, if it is a noun, you… person or thing, irikh, you cannot use GERN, you can use Mjogen.
Ishak VT: Ishmaq, Ishmaq music, Ishmaq Maria.
Ishak VT: actually press GAN, that's it.
Ishak VT: Verplus GAN.
Ishak VT: Gad.
Ishak VT: So, ich drink coffee. Trinken is an action, right? Ich trinkafe. Ich jore gern music. So, that's it. Noun, right?
Ishak VT: You can… the same thing, you can use, the same thing.
Ishak VT: The same thing, you can say, GIFALEN, you know the verb GIFALEN.
Ishak VT: Gefalan, you know the verb, guffilin? What is it? Gifallen.
Ishak VT: As a native verb, right?
Arafath: like…
Ishak VT: Like. This is also like. How do you use the same sentence?
Ishak VT: with GIF filing.
Ishak VT: Bitter.nie.
Ishak VT: Bitter.
Ishak VT: Someone, please, we have shown Ishma T, same sentence, you can see, you can use with Gefalan.
Ishak VT: Gefalen is a verb, ish, ish gefalen? No.
Ishak VT: You should give…
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: It's a…
Ishak VT: It's a… it's a… thing about that verb, okay? Not all the verbs like this. Gefwallen is a tricky verb.
Ishak VT: Gefahlen. Ich Gefalen.
Ishak VT: Then, teno.
Ishak VT: It's no… it's wrong.
Ishak VT: Here, gefileen verb is… In that verb.
Ishak VT: whoever is drinking, liking something, that person becomes dartif, and the T becomes subject. So?
Arafath: Dude.
Ishak VT: 30…
Arafath: J, gefold meh.
Ishak VT: I failed.
Ishak VT: Very sure about that. GIFELT, okay. GIFELT. So, never again say singular conjugation of GEFALEN is GIFEILT, okay?
Ishak VT: I want that sure and clarity at the end of bed. Yeah? That's why I reiterate
Ishak VT: I very strongly say that you sh… you learn what is the… when you… when I ask you what is a Zion, what is Zion Preparatory term, war, and the moment you say var, and Ishwar, do vast, war, that's Abesh, auf dieseweiser Geland.
Ishak VT: Give failed to me, yeah.
Ishak VT: Ennika.
Ishak VT: How do you… Tamil for Tamil, it will be perfect.
Ishak VT: And it could tell you, like… Right? What is it?
Ishak VT: What is it?
Ishak VT: The same sentence, you can say, mirr, you can start with object, no problem. Mehr gefelt.
Ishak VT: that T.
Arafath: Nanurupam, Tiki.
Ishak VT: Not good.
Ishak VT: Dirika, any good tea?
Arafath: really…
Ishak VT: Ericum, order what? Ishta Mirikum or something, right?
Arafath: Nan, nan, take care of them.
Ishak VT: No, and it could, right?
Ishak VT: Okay, Nikke is dartif.
Ishak VT: Okay, in my… in Malayalam, any ke… D… Ishtamana. That's it. Nikk.
Arafath: Safety with them.
Ishak VT: Yeah, but in English, I is a subject. I like tea.
Ishak VT: So, the same thing, you can say, may get failed. So, gefalen and me organ is an action.
Ishak VT: And gefalen, you can see, sorry, a noun, proper noun. Action, you want to say, I like to do something.
Ishak VT: Ish makagean. Ish yoregan. Ish pilagan foosball.
Ishak VT: That is, Mjogen, Gefalen, Again, this is a Dreisacher. This verb meant this is Jorengen.
Ishak VT: twink again.
Ishak VT: So, action pandemarekum, or usaha istameerikum, or thing.
Ishak VT: Or a person. That is Mark. So, I like…
Ishak VT: you… you can say, I like Germany, how do you say? Ich Magd Deutschland.
Ishak VT: That is easy.
Ishak VT: With Gifallen, how do you say?
Ishak VT: Mir Enek?
Ishak VT: They failed? What?
Ishak VT: Deutschland. Deutschland is a subject.
Ishak VT: GIF failed?
Ishak VT: Deutschland. Oder Deutschland gefelt mirrors.
Ishak VT: Oglich.
Ishak VT: Deutschland.
Ishak VT: Gefelt?
Ishak VT: Mia.
Ishak VT: So, does this verb meet again?
Ishak VT: Me organ?
Ishak VT: Let's suppose, a thing, okay?
Ishak VT: Zacha.
Ishak VT: Zach Person.
Ishak VT: Zacha oder person.
Ishak VT: something. Zacha, or, like, event.
Ishak VT: A fussball. Ichmark Fussball.
Ishak VT: Ich spiele Gernfussball. Action. Ich spielen gernfussball, ischmark Fussball. So Gefarlen…
Ishak VT: Gefahlen is auch… No, Zacha.
Ishak VT: Zacha, per zone, event, anything. It can be anything, okay? Noun. That means this all becomes with noun.
Ishak VT: is equal to noun.
Ishak VT: This is also… there should be a noun.
Ishak VT: That's it.
Ishak VT: Dys auch naun? Norman.
Ishak VT: Here, there is web.
Ishak VT: Here is web.
Ishak VT: That's it.
Ishak VT: Feb pleskirnen.
Ishak VT: Ishmag Maria.
Ishak VT: How do you say, I like to meet Maria? How do you say?
Ishak VT: use meat, trephin, yeah? Ish?
Ishak VT: Trafe? What? What do you add? Game, Maria.
Ishak VT: Verstanden.
Ishak VT: Are you getting what I mean?
Ishak VT: Happensi, fishtanden was sich minor.
Ishak VT: Hello, Habanzi, ya or Anisht?
Ishak VT: Yeah, or the 9. Yeah.
Ishak VT: Which is a Haganzi? Why do you make me ask this… whether you understand this? I'm asking twice or three times for you to answer. How pathetic, I don't see, I don't… I don't understand this.
Ishak VT: You just tell me whether you understood or not. If not, I can explain it very clearly.
Ishak VT: It's… it's such a simple topic, anybody can understand. So, haben sie das verstaden?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Yes, from my end.
Ishak VT: Alejandra?
Ishak VT: Arafat Habanzi?
Ishak VT: If not, no problem! It's not everybody can understand everything new.
Ishak VT: You, you have a note?
Ishak VT: Oh my god. Yes, you have been. Ali Antara. So, should I ask everyone on call whether you understand? If you don't understand, tell me no. Otherwise, yes, please.
Ishak VT: Why are you making me tell me… this asks such a simple and silly questions three times? You know, it takes a lot of…
Ishak VT: Hard work to speak, you know? Taking 2 hours continuously, and another class after that.
Ishak VT: It's a lot of work.
Ishak VT: Okay.
Ishak VT: At least Yah or a 9, that's okay. Fine. Okay, Ishtrafiggehan Maria, this is action. Ishmag Mariah.
Ishak VT: Me feel to Maria.
Ishak VT: Okay, Maria Enikishthamana. Mariah enikishtamana. Ishta means, liben is a love, okay? Love and like is different. Love is something… yeah.
Ishak VT: You know. So… Ichpiele.
Ishak VT: Gern Fussball.
Ishak VT: I like to.
Ishak VT: playful.
Ishak VT: That's so important. I like football-ish-ish mark fussball, or the megafelt fussball.
Ishak VT: Okay, if you like to play, this is important. Like to play something, this is the whole zaha.
Ishak VT: play football.
Ishak VT: So, like to pray.
Ishak VT: This is it, along with… this is like to myths.
Ishak VT: I. Like… to meet… Maria.
Ishak VT: like to meet. Action. Here, Okay.
Ishak VT: here… Ish.
Ishak VT: Mag Maria.
Ishak VT: Marie is a person. I like her. So, ishpiele again, football, I like to play football, but…
Ishak VT: If you want to say, Ich… ich be… ichthink. Ja, ichtinke.
Ishak VT: Gunn… Coffee.
Ishak VT: I like to.
Ishak VT: What is it? I?
Arafath: I like to drink.
Ishak VT: Mmm.
Ishak VT: Coffee.
Ishak VT: I like to drink. But if you want to say, I prefer to drink coffee, how do you say?
Ishak VT: I prefer to drink coffee.
Ishak VT: Prefer is what?
Ishak VT: Adenic coloninacal for glycin.
Ishak VT: Compare. I skipped coffee and tea, but I like, I prefer.
Ishak VT: Coffee. Adene kal idi, ishtamana. Besar hours. Yeah, it is a gen ka comparativis ish.
Ishak VT: Cinque Lib Coffee.
Ishak VT: So, labor is not a verb.
Ishak VT: Libra is in a particle that you add with a verb to get the meaning of comparison.
Ishak VT: Hey, you come back. So, ichthinker Lieber Cafe?
Ishak VT: our state.
Ishak VT: What is the meaning?
Arafath: I like to… I like to.
Ishak VT: Green?
Ishak VT: I like to drink coffee.
Arafath: empty.
Ishak VT: Dante. So?
Ishak VT: It's not like, actually.
Ishak VT: I prefer to drink.
Ishak VT: Like, prefer?
Ishak VT: is, prefer.
Ishak VT: So, gen comparative labor am libsten.
Ishak VT: the most. I like the most. I prefer to drink Coffee… Done.
Ishak VT: T.
Ishak VT: You don't need, I'll stay here. When you say, es gebt zweiser ich tinke liber cafe bedeut, es gibb 2isage, out of that, I prefer cafe.
Ishak VT: I prefer to drink coffee. So, can we change to liber. Libre is not a verb.
Ishak VT: A verb is something that we conjugate, okay?
Ishak VT: Here.
Ishak VT: Football and cricket.
Ishak VT: Ich spielen gern fussball bedoit, I like to…
Ishak VT: Ich spielenk gern fussball, ich ghileb gern cricket.
Ishak VT: Whatever. If you want to negate, you can just put nicht in front of gun. Nicht gun.
Ishak VT: I don't like.
Ishak VT: I don't like to… So
Ishak VT: We have been cricket and fussball. So, which one do you like to prefer to play?
Ishak VT: Icht isch spieler, Lieberfussbaul als Cricket.
Ishak VT: ka.
Ishak VT: prefer.
Ishak VT: So, labor is preferred.
Ishak VT: prefer to also. So, Ich sting becomes, I like to… drink.
Ishak VT: Ich sting labor becomes?
Ishak VT: I prefer to drink.
Ishak VT: If you want to compare.
Ishak VT: Then I call Edesh Tamarik. Then I call other Cyanesh Tamarik.
Ishak VT: So, ich tinke lieber cafe arsi. I prefer to drink.
Ishak VT: In your sentence, labor is something that… So, they prefer to sit with mobile, or they prefer to spend time with mobile. How do you say?
Ishak VT: The Eugentin, Jungen, Eugent lichen, the Arfat, Eugent lichen.
Ishak VT: The youth,
Ishak VT: Preferred to spend time with Hanti, or the worse. Yeah, meat hanty, right?
Ishak VT: What is… spend time? What is the verb? You have to get the verb and add labor.
Ishak VT: What is spend time? I have already, many times I've said, what is a spend time?
Ishak VT: What is the verb for that?
Ishak VT: I spend time with my family-ish?
Arafath: Spend time…
Ishak VT: Verbringen, right? Furbringen. Furbringen away, please!
Ishak VT: Very disappointed, I am saying very disappointed, because you are not high.
Ishak VT: very furbringing. I was not like this.
Ishak VT: So, if I were like this, I would not be teaching today.
Ishak VT: I'm telling the truth.
Ishak VT: I studied German, very little time, very little time, 2 months ich spur der Sagen.
Ishak VT: Even I didn't go to college for classes, but I studied. But when I studied, I studied.
Ishak VT: I studied.
Ishak VT: That's what, if you do that, hard work pays off. Otherwise, nothing. So, fair bring… the younger lesion, fair bringin'…
Ishak VT: So, if you want to use liber in ascendants, I'm saying, so, Ferbringen, lib, Libre…
Ishak VT: The site, field site, Det side.
Ishak VT: They prefer to.
Ishak VT: site… Meet?
Ishak VT: Hunty. Meet them hunty, meet, mit hunty.
Ishak VT: So, this is a sentence. The young people
Ishak VT: prefer to spend time with the handic, that's it.
Ishak VT: Sie haben viele andere option, ja? Sie konnen mit Freunden verbr bringen.
Ishak VT: to labor. Preferred to.
Ishak VT: So, the youth… The youngs, the youngesters, the youth.
Ishak VT: prefer to.
Ishak VT: prefer to spend time. You see, for bringing Lieber.
Ishak VT: So, GAN, if you use GAN, that's also fine.
Ishak VT: That's also fine. The change, it will prefer to will change, like, to spend.
Ishak VT: time… with handy.
Arafath: Meet handyman.
Arafath: Meet hunting. With hunting.
Ishak VT: We'll be.
Ishak VT: Meet them handy.
Ishak VT: You can just use some nouns you don't have to actually… always you don't have to add article, but better.
Ishak VT: Preferred to spend time with mobile.
Ishak VT: Mobile. Mobile phone. Summit hunt.
Ishak VT: That's it. That's what you wanted to write here. I'm thinking. So, in sie spritz sent in von Inen. Correct.
Ishak VT: Very good. Mit ERM.
Ishak VT: Mobile telephone, so… The same thing. ABBA… But… 90%?
Ishak VT: present.
Ishak VT: Von Einen. Very good.
Ishak VT: Von Ehenen.
Ishak VT: Is it capital you have written? A small letter, right? From them.
Ishak VT: 90% of them, of them, fairbring and plural.
Ishak VT: Libe die zeit mitam.
Ishak VT: prefer to spend time. Meet, meet, Ehren.
Ishak VT: Whatever you have written here in mobile telephone, mobile…
Ishak VT: Telephone. They're good. Good point, right? I… I would say.
Ishak VT: Okay, that's good. Okay, handis haben forum nachtail.
Ishak VT: Okay? Handies, or a mobile telephone. For if you have to put an apostrophe. How do you say it together? For tile or a nachtail, when you say that.
Ishak VT: You have to set this 4… Sorry.
Ishak VT: Und nachteilerteiler.
Ishak VT: This is it. So, that means for Tyler or nach Tyler. This tile comes with 4 and NARCH.
Ishak VT: If you put this, it's wrong. You have to put it this way. If you are putting that… this is for Tyler Nachtailer, yeah? So, 4 and noctila. So, it's that way. Okay.
Ishak VT: Oh, very short, but whatever you have written is perfect.
Ishak VT: Okay.
Ishak VT: Good job, Knudsen. So, you could use better word, better version, Junge Leuter, solten das hanti, nu fuh, nudzlich Sachen Benutzen, or da. Guter Sacher, good things.
Ishak VT: Editing minutes and notes.
Arafath: reading you.
Ishak VT: Knudsen. Junge Leutches, Alton?
Ishak VT: Emma Respect Elton. Zoltan? Ungoloid is Alton?
Ishak VT: E capital, Elton is plural, is, Norman, right? Respect here in. Respect here in.
Ishak VT: Zalton?
Ishak VT: So you don't have to repeat Zolten Zolten. Zolten des handi no fur gude sacher nudzen, und
Ishak VT: This is all together, right? Elton und el tereenschen? Respect ihren. How do you write this?
Ishak VT: the yoga… Jungaloite, de Jungeno, right?
Ishak VT: Jung?
Ishak VT: Leut?
Ishak VT: Zalton?
Ishak VT: Zoltan, the Sandi.
Ishak VT: notes, and you can say many things, okay? If you… Gut, sachen. Sachen.
Ishak VT: Knudsen.
Ishak VT: Und… Not zen und… ir Elton. There. Elton.
Ishak VT: owned eldera older people.
Ishak VT: Alta. That is a comparison, okay, this is a comparative degree. ALT, ELTER.
Ishak VT: Older people. Older than you. Elder. Older than them. Elder… El Ta. Re. Mention.
Ishak VT: Respect here, and… Tieren. Zolte. So, Zolteeren, Zolte nutzen. Sinef.
Ishak VT: You don't have to go that far. So, a little bit more, it's very short, okay? Very short.
Ishak VT: Whoever not done… anybody else done this? No.
Ishak VT: No, right?
Ishak VT: Okay.
Ishak VT: It's okay, I don't, I don't mind. I can't, I cannot beg… This is…
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Yesterday's one, right?
Ishak VT: Yesterday, yeah. Sanchi has done so good, yeah?
Ishak VT: It's, since she has the letter, I would, I would read. Kommen.
Ishak VT: So, what is a frag? The Freundin komt zum Besuch, yeah? Comt besuchen.
Ishak VT: Okay?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: This is STD's, I mean…
Ishak VT: Yes, I know, I know, I know.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: refreshing.
Ishak VT: Day before yesterday. So, a friend of you, you, coming from, some other country to visit you in your country, so you are explaining which time is, which yard site is to Bessa? Fyo Besuch, so that's it.
Ishak VT: What do you mean here?
Ishak VT: vielen dank, fur mich sehen kommen.
Ishak VT: For coming to meet me, right?
Ishak VT: Okay. Feel… Okay, vielen dang, fuh dein besuch. That's enough, you cannot use this.
Ishak VT: Vielen dank, fur mish?
Ishak VT: What is the meaning? Feel… a lot of thank you for me, Z, comment. No, you cannot use this.
Ishak VT: How do you say?
Ishak VT: do, mich.
Ishak VT: Besuchen.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Bizouken, okay.
Ishak VT: Besugen. Oda, it's a noun, you need a noun, actually, here.
Ishak VT: The word would be ich freem mich auf dein besuck.
Ishak VT: Dineriza.
Ishak VT: I'm looking forward, I'm eagerly waiting for your riser.
Ishak VT: Comma, not coma.
Ishak VT: Ich bin seh aufgend.
Ishak VT: Uber mich sehen D.
Ishak VT: And… what is it? Me meeting you.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Excited to see you.
Ishak VT: Oh, it's right. Excite, I know, this is Ich bin sehr auf Geregend.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: to see you.
Ishak VT: to see you, what we learned. We have… we have been… I'm so infinitive Gillant, yeah?
Ishak VT: To see you, what is this to sayin?
Ishak VT: Ib bin seh aufgend coma.
Ishak VT: Dich zu sehen.
Ishak VT: That's why emote… that's a very important part of German sentence.
Ishak VT: Too infinitive.
Ishak VT: Okay.
Ishak VT: How do you ride this?
Ishak VT: Ish bin?
Ishak VT: Ich bin se begeister, you can say?
Ishak VT: Zia… Auf?
Ishak VT: Auf?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: African.
Ishak VT: Aufregan, right? Aufregan.
Ishak VT: Or the Be Geistet kernst du auch.
Ishak VT: Big guy's dirt.
Ishak VT: comma, dish… Suzanne.
Ishak VT: Da habier.
Ishak VT: So, Triffin, to meet you. So infinitive is like this. To meet you. You're writing here and there.
Ishak VT: Sue Triffin.
Ishak VT: That's it.
Ishak VT: Tish, and all these many things, you see.
Ishak VT: Mish, aufgearent mish sein dish.
Ishak VT: N… Ninne meet.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Trying to make sense.
Ishak VT: This is me, this is… U.
Ishak VT: I visit you, no, you visit me, right?
Ishak VT: Why, why did you use sagt?
Ishak VT: Ich mir ochste sagen. Mjochten is modal verb amende.
Ishak VT: Infinitive. Ich mir ochste sagen, where… Ausflugen Sold Dishmarks.
Ishak VT: What is the meaning? Cool?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Sir, I was…
Ishak VT: We are, we are, right?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Yeah, rare.
Ishak VT: Via?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Yeah.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Wir ausflugen.
Ishak VT: Why did you write all this Ishmoksthtesagen wirkjonen zamen ausfruger?
Ishak VT: What is it? Dishma Gizain?
Ishak VT: You see where… Wier, aus Flugen Zoel. So, where is the…
Ishak VT: I didn't get this. Wir ausflugen sol dich mag gesen.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Yeah, so…
Ishak VT: What is it?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Goodbye.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: I would like to ask you, where would you like to, go and visit?
Ishak VT: Where? What is the word for where?
Ishak VT: Where? So, it's not you are asking. The friend is coming from an unknown place. You are suggesting about your country. You know better, right?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Got it.
Ishak VT: So, you should say, this is… we… this thing. So, wirkonen zusammen die standard museum besuchen, wir haben viele in meine start oder gibtes, in minus start order land, gibtes viele museum, wirkon dies viele alter status, it is, wirkjorn die steter besiechtigen, oder besuchen.
Ishak VT: It's node. So, it's Node. If you want to say that, it's wrong. Where? Where is who?
Ishak VT: Where? Fragen, right? Not sagen.
Ishak VT: It's a question, right? Where? Wo wir die ausflugen machen.
Ishak VT: Sohen.
Ishak VT: That's all. In minus start, heart grows not hard.
Ishak VT: Haben grows a stand, or a heart grows a stand meet Ein Kaufen centrum. Ein Kaufen centrum, no. Ein Kaufcentrum, that is, shopping malls. Ein Kauf Centrum, one word. That is also capital, I, E capital. Ein Kaufen Centrum, no, there's no word such that.
Ishak VT: So here, this is correct, but…
Ishak VT: second position you have used. First, this is the first time you are using second position verb.
Ishak VT: In minus start, hateno. Why? Had, node now?
Ishak VT: Hadibuto in the hand, right?
Ishak VT: In my city, there were many stands. It's disappeared now? No.
Ishak VT: It's Haas, right? That's where we use giptas. There are… grows, strength, mid, Grosen?
Ishak VT: Einco Central.
Ishak VT: Okay. So, a hat days past, understand that difference. Haben is now… Hut in his head!
Ishak VT: You're visiting my country. My country had many beaches, but not now.
Ishak VT: You, you said there are, in meine start, gibtes viele grossest 10e mit ein Kaufcentro. That's good.
Ishak VT: Gibtus. S. Gibt.
Ishak VT: Use that. That's why we learned. Very simple thing.
Ishak VT: Essen.
Ishak VT: E capital. Fun anderen Land for Bieren.
Ishak VT: Throw beer and…
Ishak VT: Okay.
Ishak VT: Probiern. We can try.
Ishak VT: Does he say Lecker?
Ishak VT: do weirdst, where the note, learn and see the conjugation. You don't write what you think, no.
Ishak VT: That's why I told you I gave you weird and conjugation and old. Please learn, go and learn.
Ishak VT: Du wirstb best tempt gehren Essen.
Ishak VT: You would like to.
Ishak VT: The vist me organ, okay.
Ishak VT: Gearnessin, no problem. In zomer, verb second position.
Ishak VT: What is the place? Tea drink, and there's a trinken. That's very good. Kionin, but Kionan should come here. Thus is a beerumt here. Very good. Towards them, thus Weta Khan…
Ishak VT: Ferenterung.
Ishak VT: Ferendumung is a noun. Kionen braustein verb.
Ishak VT: However, towards them, the sweater, You should use FERENTERN, the verb.
Ishak VT: Towards them, no coma. Towards them, don't have a coma.
Ishak VT: In German, there is no comma between however, nothing.
Ishak VT: Here, towards SIM, Candace Weta, Frenton. Wechsel.
Ishak VT: Veter is vaxil. Okay, change weather.
Ishak VT: Bregenen.
Ishak VT: Apart from that, so, outside them, bring ganzibite, use in ascendance. Bring ganzibite kleidong und Jakimit.
Ishak VT: Of Lindish?
Ishak VT: Coma, why coma?
Ishak VT: Have you… have you ever read and see coma between Todd Sam and Hofelish? No. Read.
Ishak VT: As much as you can understand the sentence structure.
Ishak VT: To London, no? Nach London. I told you, city, Nach.
Ishak VT: Ich freue mich auf deinen Besu. This is a perfect sentence. Ja. Very good.
Ishak VT: You have attempted, but no one used shiben, we can understand. A Lord to correct. A Lord to correct, but we will do that.
Ishak VT: We will do that, we await in the Smachen, but only when you do that continuously. You need a lot of homework. A lot of homework. Yeah? In moment…
Ishak VT: Yeah, this one.
Ishak VT: Okay, this one is that. Laba Maria… Moment…
Ishak VT: Meine no nach?
Ishak VT: No, ist should come here. Second pushin, where is the verb in second position? The verb cause at the end only when enabensatz.
Ishak VT: order modal verb, second question will be modal verb. Not east, sind.
Ishak VT: Because plural. Be mindful when you write a sentence. Singular sentence? East is singular. Zind is plural. When you have any doubt, please ask me.
Ishak VT: When you write, I've written this, why it is so.
Ishak VT: I'm thinking it is like this, why it's wrong. You ask me. Be correct and go.
Ishak VT: Otherwise, it's not possible. Okay? Meineung nacht sind Junge Manschen, mention, oh manschen. Write it completely. That's why I told you, be sure about what you learn.
Ishak VT: You, you learn and wear, then?
Ishak VT: Wherein, what is where then, to become, or future.
Ishak VT: So, you don't know the conjugation. You, whenever you write, do where they. What is this?
Ishak VT: You learned the worst.
Ishak VT: be sure about the conjugation. When you use DO, use worst.
Ishak VT: Not where theych where de, where den. According to such subject, insuition, yung. In session, second question verb. Very important.
Ishak VT: East intuition, Meanwhile, East a good learner.
Ishak VT: East learning?
Ishak VT: Learnin' good, right?
Ishak VT: Intuition, meanwhile, learned in the Jungelautre good.
Ishak VT: East learning, what is this sentence structure?
Ishak VT: Have a… have we ever learned design plus learn anew?
Ishak VT: We have learned in perfect Zion plus pepe.
Ishak VT: Ich bin gegangen.
Ishak VT: Have you ever learned the infinity form of the verb amente and second position as Zain? No. Nothing.
Ishak VT: As pregnant as it is raining.
Ishak VT: The children, the young people are learning good. That's what you want to see.
Ishak VT: It's… it's not East Learnin'. Learnin' only.
Ishak VT: In session site, learnen die Junge Menschen, i lungeloute, They're good.
Ishak VT: Eskomt da Rauch an Junke Lebensmittel. What is this? I didn't get… Depends upon that?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Depends on… young people's lifestyle.
Ishak VT: 11 still, okay. Okay. Then he escomt auf…
Ishak VT: No, how to use uncommon is a separable verb, so… escomped… I'm Ende Ankams.
Ishak VT: Aufi is the proposition. S-Compt of the… Leben Stil von Jungelauter. An.
Ishak VT: Lack of practice, man. Lack of practice. S… Comte… of… Thus, Leben still? Lebens still… Fun… Jungen?
Ishak VT: Eugent Lisha, you can just use Eugent Lishin.
Ishak VT: Fund, then dartif, okay? Fund, then you can listen.
Ishak VT: An.
Ishak VT: Uncommon auch. Uncommon. This is how we use separable verb.
Ishak VT: It's A, A1 thing, okay, please, learn. It's a purple verb. If you have any doubt, ask me.
Ishak VT: And common, what, how do you say, Maria reached today? And common is to reach, and Komen AUV is to depend on. Eskomt auf dasleben Stief von Jungen Leuchte an.
Ishak VT: It depends upon the lifestyle of the people. Okay.
Ishak VT: How do you say, Maria Reed today?
Ishak VT: Maria?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Sorry, what poster.
Ishak VT: Maria, Maria is arriving today.
Ishak VT: Uncommon is the verb, right? You know.
Ishak VT: Maria?
Ishak VT: Second question verb.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Est…
Ishak VT: is to know.
Ishak VT: This no tends… Maria Comte!
Ishak VT: I told you!
Ishak VT: What is it? Maria Comte.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Maria Kunt.
Ishak VT: Beto, Maria East coming and Maria comes. Both. We don't have a tense Maria East comped now.
Ishak VT: No, such tense is not at all there in German.
Ishak VT: Zion plus Moda, there's ast common, Maria Comte.
Audio shared by Ishak VT: Comte?
Ishak VT: Oh my god.
Ishak VT: Say one thing I don't know how to…
Ishak VT: Maria Comte Hoyte Ann. That's it. Maria is coming to the reaching today.
Ishak VT: Where did you… not a single moment I said this.
Ishak VT: Maria is coming as Maria Comte.
Ishak VT: It is raining, how do you say?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: That's regret.
Ishak VT: S-regnan, not air… hysterectnin, no.
Ishak VT: S-regnate. We have a new iron in tens.
Ishak VT: Maria Comte Maria Rita studi.
Ishak VT: is arriving.
Ishak VT: What? Maria arrives today, or Maria is arriving? We haven't no visa. Sorry.
Ishak VT: Second question verb.
Ishak VT: He contributed. Maria come to Hoyte.
Ishak VT: I don't know Maria is arriving today.
Ishak VT: I don't know when is he coming.
Ishak VT: Ish?
Ishak VT: Why? I don't know.
Ishak VT: Weiss? At least you learned to say, I don't know. It's Vaishnish.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: I finished.
Ishak VT: when he is coming.
Ishak VT: When?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Von.
Ishak VT: One error?
Ishak VT: Comte.
Ishak VT: Just to comment no. When you think it's no… just don't take from English and put it there, no.
Ishak VT: When Er Comte, When is he coming? When he comes, whatever you translate, we have an intense. So.
Ishak VT: But when you say Maria arrived today, Maria?
Ishak VT: ease… Hoyte… Angie Komen.
Ishak VT: Here is I'm press… Pepe. It's not a verb. Here, what you used?
Ishak VT: East Lair, no, no.
Ishak VT: is to learn a no, not at all possible. It is a movement verb, that's why. What is the meaning? Maria?
Ishak VT: Oh.
Ishak VT: This is Maria Comte, and is Maria is arriving today. What is the meaning? East and Gekomen?
Ishak VT: Maria?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: It's coming today.
Ishak VT: No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Ishak VT: Arrived.
Ishak VT: Today.
Ishak VT: It's perfect.
Ishak VT: Why? Perfect Meet Zain?
Ishak VT: You cannot use hat, Maria, hat aute ange kommen, because uncommon to arrive is a movement verb. So, perfect mid-esign.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: It's simple present, okay.
Ishak VT: Very bitter.
Ishak VT: It's… it's what? It's perfect. Maria arrived, or Maria has arrived, both.
Ishak VT: Maria arrived, or Maria has arrived. It's a very basic A1.
Ishak VT: I don't know.
Ishak VT: Maria… Oh, my Maria. Maria has arrived. Both.
Ishak VT: Maria has arrived.
Ishak VT: One error… I don't know when he came.
Ishak VT: I don't know when he came,
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Fish Nished.
Ishak VT: Nicht?
Ishak VT: When? When.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: One…
Ishak VT: CAME. What is CAME? To come past.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Cool.
Ishak VT: Perfect, use perfect. For past, use perfect. When error.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Wow.
Ishak VT: No.
Ishak VT: Common is a movement verb. Zain plus pepe. Be sure about what you learned, please!
Ishak VT: When air gain?
Ishak VT: calm, and it's very busy.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: I went, okay.
Ishak VT: Yeah, Coleman?
Ishak VT: What is the last verb? 1, because of 1, it goes to end. You know, it's an ebenzad's indirect frag. I don't know when he is coming. Something is missing. Still, one more verb is missing.
Ishak VT: East, right?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Este, este.
Ishak VT: when he came, or when I don't… Know when
Ishak VT: He arrived, or came, alright? When he has come, whatever.
Ishak VT: For both, we have 1.
Ishak VT: Ich weiss nicht wann er kommen kommenist.
Ishak VT: When he arrived, it is Angekomenist.
Ishak VT: You have to practice many these, ponygazian. So,
Ishak VT: Mao effect and, interactive frag, that's,
Ishak VT: I don't know where to start and where to end, I'm all confused. Okay, so, okay, problem. We are machinas, yeah? Be confident. Be confident. The more you do, the better you understand.
Ishak VT: It all becomes like that. It's all. Any language, whatever in your life, you see, whatever way you come across in your life.
Ishak VT: Everything is like this. It will be hard, tough nut to crack.
Ishak VT: But it's tough not to crack.
Ishak VT: particular difficulty recall. Yeah, there's a thing. Very… it's not an easy walk. It's not a cakewalk. Everything that you face in your life.
Ishak VT: at first look, At first look, it'll be like this, a tough nut to crack.
Ishak VT: You cannot break it.
Ishak VT: But the more you practice, the more you get used to that, you'll get it. Anything, not only this, any profession in your professional life, you want to learn something.
Ishak VT: You can learn if you try.
Ishak VT: Everything is that, like that. At the first look, it will be very difficult. Okay.
Ishak VT: There are a lot of things I want to change, okay, Labelstream. Elton Zint… Wichtig in… Ambition?
Ishak VT: Elich Gesagt. Okay. El Tanzit Wichtisch Investen, what is it?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: batting socks?
Ishak VT: I?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Are more, are important to look after them.
Ishak VT: Parents are?
Ishak VT: I didn't get that sentence still not clear, English itself. Parents are…
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Okay, parents must look after their kids, that's what I'm trying to explain.
Ishak VT: die kinder, cumin.
Ishak VT: Elton, very simple verbs, you know? Mussen zorgen. Zorgen furor is the verb, sich kummern, to take care of. So.
Ishak VT: Elton Musen ihrekinderekinder, mussen sich Umiere Kinden, Kumen.
Ishak VT: Very easy. Elish Giza, to be honest. No coma. Why this? I don't understand.
Ishak VT: Sindman, verb, second position, sind mancheunge, it's also wrong, small letter.
Ishak VT: Junggeloyte. Jungaloita?
Ishak VT: Good concentrate in studio, not studiern. Studium. Noun is studium. Studierin is a verb.
Ishak VT: concentration of… concentrate auf?
Ishak VT: To diem. My stance, no coma.
Ishak VT: Sind Jungel von Berlin mehr.
Ishak VT: Mayor et Sogen Arts Frankfurt. Okay.
Ishak VT: Okay, mystens in the eugen lesion… Owls…
Ishak VT: Berlin, not fun. Aus from Berlin. Ich ko mein Aus Berlin, yeah? Aus Berlin…
Ishak VT: meher etsogen als die Junge aus Frankfurt. That's how you use.
Ishak VT: They are more brought up good, very good educated, than the youngsters.
Ishak VT: From the Frankfurt, yeah? How do you write? Meistense? Sind die Jugendlische aus Berlin. Mehr etzogen, als die Jungeen, aus Frankfurt. Besunders, no comma.
Ishak VT: Yarfun.
Ishak VT: Oh… Beson des…
Ishak VT: sind, die Kinte, die Junge von firzhen bis 20 Jare alt sind. Von… von fiert sich und Swansich.
Ishak VT: Concentrate to diet, best serve vegan.
Ishak VT: TSC.
Ishak VT: why zinc concentrates to DRN? You know, you see our study, Okay. Beson das studieren.
Ishak VT: You very easy thing, Zint studier, and I don't understand what this… Zine plus…
Ishak VT: this… we have… have you ever learned? I don't know. I didn't teach. Besundes Studieren, die Junge von mit jaar finseen sich concentrate, pessa.
Ishak VT: Or the concentrated base, vegan THC, and so. What is this? I don't know. Sie beste di perfume. Sie bestein. Comano, full stop. Sie bestene die perfume, mousse.
Ishak VT: Oh? You see, here verb, this verb, how come you use MUS here? I don't understand.
Ishak VT: I… for good universe. The… the pa… they pass? What do you… what do you mean? They pass?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: So…
Ishak VT: They passed?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: They'll go to good university.
Ishak VT: Sie mussen die Privungen?
Ishak VT: when Z…
Ishak VT: When they want to, Mjoksten, when they… Bekomen, when they want to get a good university, they must
Ishak VT: So they… you have a structure for that. Manchester Diet, Manchester dieeren, aufieren Fall ist einfar, studieren ist, here one verb, here on one verb, it's… German, it's not like, not even any language, it's not like that. English, you… many studies.
Ishak VT: Einfach, des gut disciplines.
Ishak VT: Okay, Shikkan, I will contact you.
Ishak VT: Okay? Okay, now in Ken problem, we are keen on the smacken, yeah?
Ishak VT: Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Ishak VT: A lot. Please.
Ishak VT: Work hard. Otherwise,
Ishak VT: It will be… all will be a futile exercise. Futile exercise, but donated, useless exercise. Coming to class, spending 2 hours.
Ishak VT: It's all gonna be a futile exercise when you don't practice.
Ishak VT: If you don't put your head into that.
Ishak VT: It's a very easy, simple thing. Nothing complicated. But, only thing that you need to do is, you have to practice.
Ishak VT: You have to practice.
Ishak VT: Okay.
Ishak VT: Yeah, yeah. I think, hopefully, I'm sending all this, thinking that you will have at least one look and learn this, okay?
Ishak VT: Please do it.
Ishak VT: I… I trust you.
Ishak VT: You see?
Ishak VT: Meinung Shreib, and I had given something here. I had sent it.
Ishak VT: So, follow these, at least. At least, you see.
Ishak VT: Use. At the end, you see.
Ishak VT: at least…
Ishak VT: at least use this. Fleisch.
Ishak VT: At conclusion, you say, at least use it.
Ishak VT: to salmon fastened. This is all the same for any language, any topic.
Ishak VT: kann man zagen.
Ishak VT: The… what is it? The Jugen cliche?
Ishak VT: A sind…ichindelich?
Ishak VT: Respectful, and oh, whatever. You can just conclude the sentence.
Ishak VT: See, outside them. When I used AUSADEM, please have a look at this.
Ishak VT: Some verb I used first, no, coma. Have you seen? Here, coma, no.
Ishak VT: is there? No. German coma when you separate between sentences.
Ishak VT: Not otherwise. In German, you… in English, you will see how… however, comma. No? In German, no.
Ishak VT: You see, main meinung nach, ist verb I used.
Ishak VT: at least…
Ishak VT: taught some…
Ishak VT: comma I'm using, because I'm separating this sentence, the skip twice aza. Separating between two, so das that's an ich dunk.
Ishak VT: So, when you say… Okay.
Ishak VT: Where to start, I'm not getting any.
Ishak VT: Hmm…
Ishak VT: It's all I've sent you, you know? Kion, and you can…
Ishak VT: Ich wir Konen. It's… nobody should say to you, Kyon and Kionen. Okay.
Ishak VT: Let me shut,
Ishak VT: Yeah, these, what, our byte.
Ishak VT: Okay.
Ishak VT: This one…
Ishak VT: Hopefully, we can stop the class, I'm a little bit tired, and… Disappointed a little bit.
Ishak VT: So it's Zagen.
Ishak VT: So, we can just start with the chapter.
Ishak VT: Okay, please do work hard.
Ishak VT: A little bit. Dunker, it's okay, you're working, I know, but…
Ishak VT: A little bit more concentration is required.
Ishak VT: No, Kim.
Ishak VT: So, we begin in mid.
Ishak VT: Capital… comparative, right?
Ishak VT: Please learn an exhibit.
Ishak VT: Yeah, here, capital.
Ishak VT: wir haben schon discotheet.
Ishak VT: unweld Freundlich, ja?
Ishak VT: leisch.
Ishak VT: Les… lazy days in text here.
Ishak VT: Bit.
Ishak VT: think was a febrout. Febreuchen is use, sa laser diesen, so I look up the dictionary and find the answer, find the text, meaning of the text, okay, bit…
Ishak VT: Okay, Shibin Tarug.
Ishak VT: So, did you understand everything?
Ishak VT: In this sentence. Deutschland protag.
Ishak VT: I don't know how many liters. Inn Deutschland Protag. Eigentlich sinde soger Knab.
Ishak VT: Narungsmittel is a nutrition food, okay? Mitt Rechnitz.
Ishak VT: Trinkwasan? What is Trinkwasan?
Ishak VT: Chinkuaza.
Fathima Afna: Dreaming water.
Arafath: Drinking more.
Ishak VT: Verbrauchen?
Ishak VT: Consume, consume, consume. Year dimension is the subject here.
Ishak VT: in Deutschland. So, protagonist was Peday.
Arafath: B.
Fathima Afna: Would be.
Ishak VT: Per day. Per day. So, like that. So, it's… it's some reading material, okay? Fleischist, Jed mensch into… So, we feel a kilo?
Ishak VT: I don't know the exact number, okay? 9500, Fleisch.
Ishak VT: ist kiloh Fleisch ist jedermensch. Jedermensch ist… Every man.
Ishak VT: In Deutschland, emyar. In a year.
Ishak VT: Das Enspicht einem hall Brinten Schinden und, jahren.
Ishak VT: That is equivalent to… that is equivalent to… this is equivalent to… Schweinen is a pig, okay, Schweinen.
Ishak VT: Huntern. Hunen is a chicken. Hunted. Ein Huntet. Inner hal von sehen Jarren.
Ishak VT: within… 10 years.
Ishak VT: Their market telephone biofleich, leaked by Noah Sir Katzent. So, BioFleisch is bio-made.
Ishak VT: in the market is that market share of BioFlash is about
Ishak VT: 2%. All others, cutting a sharp, yeah? Cutting the flesh. So, it's about unwelt, yeah? Unwelt.
Ishak VT: What is the meaning? Ish-weiss nicht is? I don't know. Ichaben nicht gewist?
Ishak VT: WISEN. WISEN, the verb, listen, conjugation is very important, okay?
Ishak VT: conjugation.
Ishak VT: I shall be shown this, exact wissen, the verb wissen. Ichweiss, du weist, Erie is weiss, wie wissen, je wist, sie wissen. Ich wuster, I knew. Du wussest.
Ishak VT: You know, soy.
Ishak VT: You learn this!
Ishak VT: That means listen verb, when you… it's, it's a verb, huh? This verb, when it's man.
Ishak VT: use Panda, this verb.
Ishak VT: So, vistin, you cannot afford to miss the conjugation of presence.
Ishak VT: Pretend it to me.
Ishak VT: Worcester is the preteritum. Ishwester, the Worcesterst.
Ishak VT: He knew that.
Ishak VT: Ervusta das.
Ishak VT: He knew Maria, where is Maria coming from?
Ishak VT: in new.
Ishak VT: What is a perfect?
Ishak VT: I have known. Duhast gewust, erhat gewust, wie haben gewust.
Ishak VT: Okay.
Ishak VT: So, I'll… let me tell you one story.
Ishak VT: Ziva se schlicht in artsway.
Ishak VT: institution, organiziert hat eine profum organisiet, sie hat nur einfuhenfunkte bekommen.
Ishak VT: Schlicht.
Ishak VT: Because alla and dereh student in mahindi usafka be here in Tag.
Ishak VT: So that was… I was thinking…
Ishak VT: This student won't make it. Not a single… you will feel very pathetic. At least you can write this much sentences here and there, you write some missing verb, and something is there only. That student was very pathetic, I was really disappointed, actually.
Ishak VT: I didn't know. I was really disappointed. It was, like, 2-3 years back, I think. She wanted to fly to Germany. Okay.
Ishak VT: So, she was, kind of, very pathetic and very bad, and I thought she would never pass.
Ishak VT: So, all other students, I told you, all other students, they wrote B2 with B1 class. My B1 class, I taught them, I gave them extra, they worked extra. They sent me, you know, I had no rest. They will keep on sending WhatsApp, this thing. They will write this much and send it to me.
Ishak VT: one essay, long essay, and send it to me. I have to check everything, and so that was good. I was very interested in that. I spent time for that, because they are working hard.
Ishak VT: So, I worked, and they worked.
Ishak VT: all past the exam, this, including this, yeah, I'll tell you, and I called her parents. Her parents called me. One is that she wants to go to Germany, that is a must, and this and so.
Ishak VT: You are saying this, I sent the works, the homeworks done by her friends, her classmates.
Ishak VT: And I sent to her father, and look at this.
Ishak VT: This is how other students respond.
Ishak VT: When I ask for doing homework, so, not a single page is left with the students without doing this Arbites book. Every single line they have worked.
Ishak VT: In our bytes book. A1, A2.
Ishak VT: Completely, completely marked House of Carbon. Never such a badge.
Ishak VT: I had in my life. That was the wound I schoonber. Only one lady, one girl, you know? This girl was after… she was not even the 5% of the mark she didn't have. Not even 5%.
Ishak VT: Her parents was very… they were very rich, and they were very eager to go to Germany, because her sister and brother is there in Germany, so she also wants to go to Germany.
Ishak VT: So… her parents was, please, sir, please take her. So, I asked, Look what others do.
Ishak VT: How much work they are doing.
Ishak VT: And after all this work, they are good.
Ishak VT: They are able to speak German, able to write German.
Ishak VT: read and understand German, because they work this much.
Ishak VT: I send the audio recordings they send me.
Ishak VT: They… what they do, you know?
Ishak VT: You see, suppose.
Ishak VT: here, we are speaking about unwelt, unwelt. So, we have been mule, ferpakum, but this mule is, waste, yeah? Ferpakum package, lang and transport wage. So, when a saga, this…
Ishak VT: ein Gisch.
Ishak VT: a conversation between two friends, and they call, they make a conversation, very good conversation, they send it to me, I get that corrected.
Ishak VT: And they record that, literally record that conversation. They call each other, and record that conversation, and send it to me. And there, also, I do corrections. And I send all the video recordings and audio recordings, they send it to me.
Ishak VT: I sent to the parent.
Ishak VT: So, this is what this… what they do.
Ishak VT: And I called this student also.
Ishak VT: You're complaining about this. So what are… there's the progress of… you look at the progress of others.
Ishak VT: And I don't know. I don't know. That was… she took it very seriously. After A2, okay, after A to B1, it was… okay?
Ishak VT: I had to.
Ishak VT: I could visibly see that progress, man.
Ishak VT: Progress means her pronunciation was very bad. I don't know, I was thinking, this girl, you know, out 9 other students were perfect.
Ishak VT: They working hard and everything, I was extra happy about them.
Ishak VT: This girl, you know.
Ishak VT: I was re… I was sure that she… whatever he… she does, because her writing was so slashed.
Ishak VT: Not even a sentence. So, I was pretty sure that she would not make it. Even if she tries 2 months sitting with German, she won't be able to.
Ishak VT: But what happened after this call, you know? Something, some wonder happened.
Ishak VT: I could see the response from her, the work that she started doing it.
Ishak VT: And she was one of the best at the end of B1.
Ishak VT: She was the best student in the class.
Ishak VT: That was the moment I thought in my life. That was a change in my life.
Ishak VT: don't ever look down upon anyone. If you see a student weak in something, Don…
Ishak VT: Don't underestimate the power of These… these people.
Ishak VT: Anyone can, if they try, if they decide, They can make it anyone.
Ishak VT: That was the moment that changed my mind. Any student who is weak today, you can't be looked down upon. That means looked down upon, beloved.
Ishak VT: Don't belittle. Don't… don't see them little. They have a power. If they want something, they can.
Ishak VT: So she tried like anything. She, you know, I can show you her chat in my WhatsApp. Maybe it's a… it's some kind of 3 years back?
Ishak VT: So, two and a half years back, so I think it's a… it might have gone from my laptop. I don't know. Whatever. So…
Ishak VT: she was… she… she went to Germany, and came back.
Ishak VT: came back. She didn't like Germany there. She came back. And now, she is one of the best teachers in one of the institutions, best institutions in Kochi, in Kerala.
Ishak VT: She's one of the… she's earning 1.75 per month.
Ishak VT: 6 hours a day, taking class, with teaching.
Ishak VT: She's still in contact with me, sir.
Ishak VT: I thought I would not even get, like, 50,000 a month.
Ishak VT: I was not capable of. I didn't have any degree or nothing.
Ishak VT: But this German changed my life.
Ishak VT: I went to Germany, there I didn't like the climate and everything, health problems, so I had to come back.
Ishak VT: After coming back, I was thinking what to do.
Ishak VT: then I gave her… so I got an opportunity, I got an advertisement, my friend called me, is there someone who can teach German?
Ishak VT: So I told the inexperienced student of mine, she can teach, you can take her. So I just, so that person, that friend of mine asked me, you conduct interview, I conducted interview.
Ishak VT: And for the sake of interview, and I told, I gave all the tips, and she started teaching.
Ishak VT: She started teaching, and she is now the… one of the best. Till that person, that institution, the manager of that… director of that institution contacts me.
Ishak VT: That was the best decision you did. So, she is earning, like, apart from tax and tax deduction and all, 1.75 lakh Indian rupees per month.
Ishak VT: Not even an engineer can get it. With 6 hours class a day.
Ishak VT: You see?
Ishak VT: That was a… a turning. So, you should never…
Ishak VT: underestimate someone because of their learning or something. Anybody Will have a spark.
Ishak VT: Okay, so that's what I'm saying. If…
Ishak VT: That girl could do that. Anybody could do that, because she was so weak.
Ishak VT: one with, what, B1, she wrote B2 and passed that exam.
Ishak VT: So, her hard work was such… a mind-blowing…
Ishak VT: So that's why you know this much. You are not…
Ishak VT: that very weakest students in the class. No one. Everybody is a… I can see,
Ishak VT: everyone is in the same level, kind of, yeah? Everyone knows something, somewhere, something missing, but yeah, something. But you are not the weakest. You are not the weak. Because you didn't get the proper training, you are… you missed something. We are learning it. We are wearing this learning.
Ishak VT: I'm okay.
Ishak VT: I… I don't want to.
Ishak VT: Okay.
Ishak VT: Okay, that's, the sisters. I just want to… Say that thing to you.
Ishak VT: Baden oder douche.
Ishak VT: Take bath in tub. What is burden? This is burden.
Ishak VT: In bath, take bath.
Ishak VT: Dushin is showering, to take shower.
Ishak VT: escape in the shade session. Plastic order, glass flusher. Glass bottle? Flasher is a bottle. Plastic flusher und glass flush. Welche ist und Umweltfreinlich. What is best of the umwelt?
Ishak VT: What's for Mutancy? What's… what do you guess?
Ishak VT: Out of this Badanoda Dushin, was this unveldt friendly? Was this Bessafu umweld?
Ishak VT: Mita. What is that?
Ishak VT: What is… Plastic flasher oder glass flasher.
Ishak VT: I guess she's too late.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: prefer environment.
Ishak VT: Environment. What's the space of your environment? Badenodushin.
Ishak VT: Plastic flush odor burden.
Ishak VT: Or the douchein.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: button.
Ishak VT: It's a plastic, or flasher, or the glass flasher.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Glass flashing.
Arafath: We'll spell.
Ishak VT: Geschispuhle oder von Hanspuhlen.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Hanspluhen.
Ishak VT: Hansplen.
Ishak VT: Book or the e-book.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: ebook.
Ishak VT: ebook.
Ishak VT: Aber duchen ist umwalt freinlicher Als. Baden.
Ishak VT: We have to airfuhlen. Bad tub mussen wir airfuhlen mit wasser. Wir brouchen viel wasser. Baden, wenn wir bar den.ig water.
Ishak VT: Lesser water.
Ishak VT: Vinny kawasa.
Ishak VT: But you broke it.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: You shouldn't just spend lots and gallons of water, right?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: It just goes… keep on going, right? But burden is just Stay safe.
Ishak VT: stays there, that's a good point. Yeah, but, you see, after you are…
Ishak VT: doing this burden, you cannot go… it's open, everything will be there. You cannot go without washing. It's completely.
Ishak VT: Afternoon is also unique.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Two times, right?
Ishak VT: Yeah, two times. You need douche dollars. Baden is un von Lische.
Ishak VT: verbraucht meinfiel was.
Ishak VT: Okay, whatsoever, whatever, whatever. It's, it's not. Arbitens, it's feared for group, feared, but if we get wealth einen text latency in node here in Z.
Ishak VT: Read this text.
Ishak VT: Geshe… Im Altak… what is Altac? Im Altak?
Ishak VT: What is the meaning?
Ishak VT: Everyday life.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: All… all day.
Ishak VT: Everyday life. All day. Everyday life. Normal life. Kann man feel fur welten. You can do a lot. Tun is a verb. This is the only verb in German which doesn't have a write an EN at the end. Tun.
Ishak VT: What can I do for you, do?
Ishak VT: So, Malta kann man feel for die welten, wenn man die richtige waldraf.
Ishak VT: What is it?
Ishak VT: Wild Triffin.
Ishak VT: And Shyrum Trophin was below it, and Shyrumtrafin.
Ishak VT: And Chadung Trifin. That's what I told you. I wrote in one…
Ishak VT: You remember?
Ishak VT: and shine.
Ishak VT: Boom.
Arafath: Decision to… To take this… to make this…
Ishak VT: You see? This is what… something that I've sent it to you, to take decision, to make decision.
Ishak VT: The same way it is I'm…
Ishak VT: I know one. One is choice.
Ishak VT: While Triffin.
Ishak VT: Ticket choice.
Ishak VT: Take a choice.
Ishak VT: wild trifin. So, we can do a lot for the environment. When you do a right choice, take a right choice.
Ishak VT: Die Richtige waltz.
Ishak VT: When you do, or take a right choice.
Ishak VT: We have… Compared ainiga, Euclobilantin, what is this? Euclobansen?
Ishak VT: Echo balance.
Ishak VT: Eco Balance. Echo balance means the environment balance. Geschispuhle von Handespuhlen.
Ishak VT: Is the Gantz Claude the best cereval? Which one is the best Ceraval?
Ishak VT: with hand order machinespuhlen.
Ishak VT: very clearly the best cereal. That's the best, the better choice. The modern machine sind efficient Geworden. What is it? Sindgeworden.
Ishak VT: What is the meaning? You have to get this meaning. In the very beginning, when you learn language, you need all this. You have to check…
Ishak VT: Sindgeworden, PP of Werden.
Ishak VT: So, what is the meaning?
Ishak VT: The modern machines?
Ishak VT: What is it? I've told you, Verdin pee-pee is gewoon.
Ishak VT: What is… how do you translate this?
Ishak VT: Efizinta Geworden.
Ishak VT: I cannot explain that. I'll just say the meaning and go, okay, please, I'm tired.
Ishak VT: The modern machine and the same kind of words we have used many sentences.
Ishak VT: If you had that… just looked at that slides and learned To have been better.
Ishak VT: So, modern machines are… machines are no…
Arafath: become, become…
Ishak VT: have become, passed, became, or became efficient order, has become, the modern machines have become more efficient, efficienter. We are learned and comparative, okay? Efficient.
Ishak VT: Efficient, more efficient.
Ishak VT: You see? Vinegar. Lesser. Less.
Ishak VT: Okay, Leservasa. Energy, Arts fewer.
Ishak VT: Danelle verbrauchen. You see?
Ishak VT: As that is… ass, right?
Ishak VT: as they modern a machine in. Z. Verbraugen consumed lesser water and energy than before.
Ishak VT: Wichtig ist, die Maschine nur einsuchalten wen sie vollinch Fall ist.
Ishak VT: Important thing is that the Machina, no Einsuchalten. Only Einschalten, Camera Einschalten, Messina Einschalten, Important is to… Einschalten.
Ishak VT: Veterans.
Arafath: Good old.
Ishak VT: Turn on. Turn on the machine.
Ishak VT: Only… Die Nuo Venzie forelist.
Ishak VT: for one… you put one shirt and turn on. This is niche deficitian.
Ishak VT: Das ist nicht unwelt.
Ishak VT: You… when the washing machine is full, fall east.
Ishak VT: Turn on the machine, know when Z the fall is.
Ishak VT: Sorry, we are talking about washing machine, nicht wash machine, Geschispuhlr. One plate you put and wash, no. Don't do that. When the wash mesh is a Geschispuhlr.
Ishak VT: Fall East.
Ishak VT: Witte schartenzie, die Machine aus ein.
Ishak VT: grosser.
Ishak VT: Mindman von Hanspuh.
Ishak VT: If you're the glyceaming, you are washing 10 plates, okay?
Ishak VT: quantity. For the… For the same quantity, for the glycemanga Geshear, from same quantity plates, Okay.
Ishak VT: plates is the bedaharfanwaja, the requirement of the water, is the field grosser, is more, bigger. The requirement of the water is bigger. When you
Ishak VT: Wash with… Hand.
Ishak VT: Baden undushin.
Ishak VT: Legacy?
Ishak VT: Again, in Badavana. Badavana is bathtub, okay? Bad tub. Bad tub. Ligansigan? What is the meaning? Ligansigern? Do you like to lay in the bathtub?
Arafath: But.
Ishak VT: You… do you like to learn? Because of learn.
Ishak VT: Sirke ein 100 fun sich.
Ishak VT: Yeah, this is A.
Ishak VT: San Shia, this is the… Mathematics.
Ishak VT: Showering.
Ishak VT: Okay, shower time, few minutes.
Ishak VT: For a… for a shower time of 5 minutes, for Brachtman, one user consume circa approximately 15 liter, 156 liter water. By burden, when you…
Ishak VT: Flutter.
Ishak VT: Under air warm, this was supposed to spill energy. Erwormic? What is it meaning? Erworm is…
Ishak VT: Wow. Erworman? To make wah.
Ishak VT: It will… in Bad, there's an option for the svasa, So, airwearman. What is airwerman?
Ishak VT: The water. You need energy for that, right?
Ishak VT: The more energy you use for the unwell, this, current you use, that's also a problem for environment, right? Unvolt, unvolt, that's a certain problem. So…
Ishak VT: For heating of the water cost us field energy.
Ishak VT: Dushan is… Dushanzi also liber.
Ishak VT: nicht.
Ishak VT: So… Do Shinzi also labor? You prefer to?
Ishak VT: Take shower.
Ishak VT: It's Baden.
Ishak VT: than taking bath in bathtub. Our laddings, however, niche laying, are same minute. Not long. If you take shower for 30 minutes, that's equivalent to this burden.
Ishak VT: nicht langer Arts.
Ishak VT: 10 minutes. So, you see Lang Langer.
Ishak VT: Venic vinegar.
Ishak VT: Gehen Lieber.
Ishak VT: Mayor. Mayor Vasa.
Ishak VT: All comparative. So sparren sie wasser und esiss viel und welt freundlicher.
Ishak VT: What is the meaning? More?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: I can be wrong, man.
Ishak VT: environment friendly. Friendly share. Friendlish is the adjective. Air is this. Let's see this.
Ishak VT: Yeah? Bethel Agency, this on this.
Ishak VT: Ebook und.
Ishak VT: mirrors, you see? More than… it's…
Ishak VT: Feel mer. Feel is the positive. Mare is more. Meist is… amiston is the most.
Ishak VT: Okay, beta. Bitter.
Ishak VT: If you read, do you read more than 10 books per year?
Ishak VT: seiten.
Ishak VT: correct creator side. Then you are on the right side of the ecological echo.
Ishak VT: Or, ecology, correct side of the ecology.
Ishak VT: So, if you… if you are reading 10 books, you are… then buy a e-book.
Ishak VT: If you use 10 times that gereta and throw away, that's a wastage.
Ishak VT: Andre.
Ishak VT: Z Cao Fernandez, so that's how… Well, but you should… bita.
Ishak VT: Whoever hasn't done that homework, please complete. Tomorrow, I'll give another one. Okay, today there's no homework.
Ishak VT: Tomorrow, Betel… okay, is Shaba, in Google Cl- in this, what, Google Classroom habeisch geschicht, die aussofgabe. Better Allah, this,
Ishak VT: bitter andere machen.
Ishak VT: Please do it, otherwise, I've…
Arafath: also covered? That's why.
Ishak VT: You do and make wrong, no problem.
Ishak VT: You do your homework and commit mistakes, it's perfectly alright. Any mistakes is allowed, but you try from your part. You're not trying, I will lose the interest, definitely. It's a case with anyone, right?
Ishak VT: I'm making sound, you are not responding. At least respond.
Ishak VT: When I ask… when I asked you whether you understood
Ishak VT: At least say that, yes or no. Sir, I didn't understand this. Something I understood. At least say that.
Ishak VT: Making me ask that question, did you understand that 3 times?
Ishak VT: First experience, let me… at least Gesacked.
Ishak VT: To be honest, first experience.
Ishak VT: Not responsive. The class is not responsive. You come to B2 class, you will understand the difference.
Ishak VT: I'm taking B2.
Ishak VT: For Gluek. You will understand. All our mic on, camera on, Don't speak
Ishak VT: Help me, they help me along. When I read something, please say the meaning, whatever they know. Mistakes, okay.
Ishak VT: I'll correct.
Ishak VT: But try!
Ishak VT: This is how you write, you see writing, you think you understand the verb, second question, but when you write, as you said, Arafat.
Ishak VT: You know many sentences, but when you write some complicated sentence, you miss something.
Ishak VT: That's okay. Quite normal.
Ishak VT: Natulich.
Ishak VT: Yeah.
Ishak VT: Thus, but you have to try. That's it. That's the only request.
Ishak VT: Plastic, plastic flashing, or glass flashing?
Arafath: Hello, Lefta Sonora.
Fathima Afna: No.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: He just left.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: He needs some time, I guess.
Arafath: Hello, and the minor,
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Walangola.
Arafath: not albinar, other than in Sonar.
Arafath: Hello and,
Arafath: Classilde.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Navigilia.
Arafath: Oh, Leo.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Thursday, right?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: okay, okay, fine, fine.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: He needs… he needs time anyhow.
Arafath: To leave a home?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: badly.
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: Yeah, if it is 9 o'clock, then we can leave, right?
Arafath: Yeah.
Arafath: Afna, Leo Omi.
Fathima Afna: Okay.
Arafath: Liva Sonava, afna?
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: I've really
Sanshiya Rameshkumar: I don't be afraid that…
Arafath: Oh my god.
Arafath: Hmm.
Arafath: Oh, wow. Thank you.
Arafath: So, Gajana, leave a home?
Kajana: Okay.
Arafath: Not until 3rd.